There's this idea in Christianity that
we've discussed briefly that the judge
and the redeemer are the same figure.
Now you know in the book of revelation,
you may know this and you may not.
Christ comes back as a judge and he has
a sword coming into a revelatory vision
that that book,
it's a very strange.
It's the last thing you'd expect.
Conservative Christians is to believe
in.
Believe me,
it's such a visionary hallucination,
the book of revelation,
but Christ comes back with a sword
coming out of his mouth and he comes
back as a judge and he divides the
damned from the redeemed and most are
damned in some are redeemed is a very,
very harsh.
Now young believed that the figure of
Christ in the Gospels was too agreeable
to merciful,
to tilted towards mercy and that that
called out for a counter position and
that was the counter position of
judgment.
Very interesting hypothesis,
but then,
but then there's this melding of the two
ideas that the judge and the redeemer or
the same thing,
okay?
Now,
this young man told me that his life
lacked purpose and direction and meaning
and that he was nihilistic until he
started.
He read Zen and the art of motorcycle
maintenance,
which is a book I actually liked quite a
bit.
I've read it three times at different
decades of my life,
and one of the things that's very
interesting about that book is that it's
an examination of the idea of quality,
of the idea that there are qualitative
distinctions between things and that we
have an instinct to make qualitative
distinctions,
and so equality is tate of distinction
is simply this is better than that,
which is a judgment.
Okay?
Now what ratzinger is hypothesizing is
that the person in and up.
You know how the idea of the modern idea
is you're supposed to accept yourself.
I think that's an insane idea,
by the way.
Really I think.
I can't think of a more nihilistic idea
then that you're already okay.
It's like,
no,
you're not,
and the reason you're not is could you
can be way more than you are,
and so what do you want to be?
You want to be okay as you are or do you
want to strive towards what's better,
and this young man,
this Australia,
and he said that the reason that Zen and
the art of motorcycle maintenance had
such an impact on him was because he
wasn't happy with his current mode of
being right.
He didn't consider the manner in which
he conducted himself sufficient and the
fact that the author of Zen,
it was laid out.
The notion that you could make
qualitative distinctions and there
really was a difference between good
things and bad things are great things
and evil things.
It gives you direction.
It gives you,
gives you the possibility of moving
upward and and ratzinger is pointing out
at least to some degree that human
beings are insufficient in and of
themselves and need the movement upward.
And so they need to conceptualize
something like the highest good and then
to strive for that.
And the thing is is that there isn't any
difference between conceptualizing the
good and being judged.
Because if you're going to conceptualize
the good and move towards what you have
to do is separate from yourself.
All those things that aren't good and
leave them behind and that's why the
redeemer and the judge or the same
thing,
and one of the things that's really
appalling,
I think about our modern world is that
we're rejecting the notion of
qualitative distinctions.
He said,
well,
we don't want to hurt anybody's feelings
by saying that one thing is better than
the other.
It's like,
okay,
fair enough.
It's not fun to be cast off with the
damned.
That's for sure,
but if people are in fact insufficient
internet in their present condition,
which seems to be the case.
I mean try finding someone who isn't.
Then if you deny the possibility of
qualitative distinction because you want
to promote a radical egalitarianism,
then you remove the possibility of
redemption because there's no movement
towards the good.
And it seems to me that it's a
catastrophe to sacrifice the good for.
Well,
it's a catastrophe to sacrifice the good
for the equal because for us to be
equal,
it would be mean as far as I can tell
that we would all be equally unredeemed
and miserable.
And so.